best guess is that china only has 1.3
billion people now the population
probably peaked more than 10 years ago
and by 2030 there will be
more retirees than workers and by 2050
the entire population of china will have
dropped below 650 million
that's wild it's beyond terminal
how real has the progress and prosperity
of the last century been in your opinion
oh it's been fantastic uh this has been
the greatest time to be alive the
combination of the american security
umbrella plus globalization
uh has changed the way we lived it's
allowed everyone to benefit from global
trade
before we had that if you didn't have
oil locally you didn't have transport
fuel if you didn't have coal locally you
didn't have electricity if you didn't
have good food locally you didn't have a
population
globalization safe globalization enabled
anyone to trade anything that they could
produce even if it wasn't a commodity
and joined the system it was like
everyone had won world war ii all at
once
it's it's been a great ride
and now it's ending
was it inevitable that it was going to
end if you'd gone back a century ago and
been able to change
policy globally
could you have done something
differently back then
uh a century ago probably not there's
there's a couple problems here so first
of all when globalization really got
going in the 50s we started moving off
the farms and into the cities to take
manufacturing jobs
now when you live
on a farm kids are free labor you have a
whole scat of them
but when you move into a condo kids are
just really loud expensive mobile pieces
of furniture and adults aren't idiots so
we had fewer
you play that forward for 70 years
and it's not that we're running out of
children that happened 40 years ago it's
that we're running out of mature adults
and so the economic model of
globalization is consumption based and
it just doesn't work without people so
we've always known we were going to get
here in the end just happen the
americans forced the issue
at the end of the war we told everyone
that we would patrol the global ocean so
that anyone could send any cargo ship
anywhere to trade in any product with
any partner
that's what made globalization work now
we didn't do this because we were nice
we didn't do this because it was a trade
program we did this as a bribe
this is what we gave everyone so that
they would join us against the soviets
the soviet union collapsed in 1992.
so americans have been electing ever
more isolationist and populist leaders
ever since
so for you to believe that globalization
can continue you have to believe that a
it doesn't require consumption anymore
and b that the americans will continue
to bleed and die so that the chinese can
get daddy you know that's a bad bet
before we start talking about where
we're at and what that means for the
future is there anything else that we
need to understand about how we got here
about any of the fundamental principles
that we're going to be talking about
i will bring them up as we go but those
are the two big things the demographic
flip well past the point of no return
and the americans have largely checked
out
you said that 2019 is the best that the
world will ever be what was particularly
special about that one yeah
so think of your demographic profile as
a pyramid children on the bottom
retirees at the top mortality built it
into a pyramid
as we
industrialize and urbanize it became
more of a column and then and eventually
an inverted v with more mature adults
than children in 2019
was the last year before the baby
boomers really got into retirement in a
big way so we had this massive post-war
generation throughout the western world
that were all on average
63.
so
they hadn't retired
yet
and all of their investments and all the
retirement savings were churning along
providing capital for the whole system
we still had a huge amount of
consumption out in the world but you
fast forward three years
this year on average they turn 66.
so
it's over we we've lose their
consumption we lose their investment
they have to liquidate all their stocks
and bonds and go into t bills in cash
because they won't have the ability to
recover from a a crash
and we're also seeing some of the
fastest demographic aging in human
history throughout the developing world
with china being the far most advanced
so we're losing the investors we're
losing the workers we're losing the
consumers all at the same time
on top of that we had trump and we had
covet and now we've got biden and then
we had brexit and everything that used
to tie it all together has been broken
apart either on purpose or just because
of the strategic trends that were
already in play
we're never going back
consumers
investors and workers those are the
three main things that people
of working age and above school age give
us
absolutely and we're running out of all
of them and you need those to continue
to grease the system they're the people
that drive not only creativity in terms
of pushing technological progress
forward and bits and pieces but they
also inject capital into the system
they're the ones that are spending on
consumer goods so on and so forth so
they just provide lubric like financial
lubrication and also uh the
um
worker power the employee employee power
right you can kind of split it into two
general categories uh for people roughly
aged 18 to 40 maybe 45 those are your
young workers relatively low value ad
relatively low cost but they're at the
height of their consumption because
they're raising kids and buying homes so
that's where most of the economic
activity that drives a modern system
comes from
once you pass 45 up until 65 the kids
are moving out the house has been paid
down but your income keeps going up so
the delta between your income and your
expenses gets very very large and that's
where all the financial heft comes from
but these are also our most productive
workers because they literally have
decades of experience
and from roughly 1985 until 2015 the
world was in kind of the perfect balance
because we had a lot of those countries
with the mature worker demographics and
then a lot with the younger worker
demographics
what's happened is that countries who
joined globalization in the second wave
in 1990s mostly the developing world
they urbanized and aged out much faster
than the rich world did
so when we hit 2015
that big chunk of developing world
workers the experienced workers the
productive workers the ones who saved
they're now moving into retirement we're
losing their money we're losing their
skills
but because the developing world is
aging so much faster
they're moving into their 40s and their
50s but they haven't been able to build
up the skill set because their systems
were not as established
but their birth rates dropped faster
than the west's did
so they actually have lower birth rates
in many cases than most of the advanced
world so we've lost children on both
sides of the ledger
and now our new mature workers just
don't have the skill set to keep it up
and even if they did they wouldn't have
anyone to sell to
when old people die do they not pass
their money down as either inheritance
or inheritance tax does that not go back
into the system in one way they do and
if they died at age 66 that would be
great from an economic point of view
unfortunately if that's the right word
uh this uh people continue on for 20 25
years after retirement now this is going
to sound really weird but in the united
states this is less of a problem
number one our baby boomers actually had
kids so we do have a replacement
generation we know them as millennials
we can talk about them later in all
their faults but ultimately they're
there and that's a good thing
uh
second
we have a really high mortality rate
among people over age 55 in the united
states i mean the the the delta between
the average age of mortality in europe
versus united states is in excess of 10
years
so we will get that churn a lot faster
than europe will
that's interesting okay so
what which countries at the moment have
got the worst demographics which
countries should be yeah which countries
should be very concerned about the ratio
of young to world
uh the worst in the world is china
they've been in the process of updating
their data over the course of the last
couple years and they're now starting to
publicly admit that they over counted by
100 million people
all of those people would have been born
since one child so age 40 and under the
young worker demographic the child
bearing demographic
and two-thirds of them are probably
women
so we best guess is that china only has
1.3 billion people now
the population probably peaked more than
10 years ago and by 2030 there will be
more retirees than workers and by 2050
the entire population of china will have
dropped below 650 million
that's wild it's beyond terminal yeah so
the chinese system collapses this decade
for sure
assuming nothing else goes wrong and
there's plenty other competitors to put
the bullet in china's head
dude that is crazy
okay so
yeah all the way from pre-industrial to
post-industrial collapse in 45 years
just for the people that don't
understand about how the one-child
policy and the preference for boys or
the girls and stuff created this
landscape what's the what's the high
level view of that sure well there's two
things um first of all of course is one
child mao was concerned that they had a
young upcoming generation after world
war ii that was going to eat the country
alive
so they went to a two-child policy
ultimately to a one-child policy and
that was not loosened until 2015 but by
that point the damage was already done
because there was a second factor
remember countries that industrialize
later can follow the path of those who
came before they can skip some steps
so china was the fastest
ever industrialization experience
what the united kingdom did in seven
generations the chinese did in one and
so they crammed seven generations of
economic growth and development into one
and that's why their growth rate has
been so impressive but you can only do
that once and now it's behind them
and now they have no children and they
have very few people under age 45.
um
is this
is population growth and collapse
similar to an our nought number in a way
that more people
allow you to have more children which
gives you more people to have more
children but if the reverse is happening
then it causes a nosedive
uh
you're absolutely right there now i
don't want to say that um unchecked
population growth is necessarily the way
to go that's not what i'm after here i
mean you require a balance between
children young workers and mature
workers if you don't have enough mature
workers you don't have the capital you
don't have enough young workers you
don't have the consumption if you don't
have the children you don't have a
future
china is already out of those last two
categories and so we know where this
leads it leads to zero
given the fact that
humans are being i think it's every
three generations lives for another
generation at the moment around about
every generation lives eight years
younger longer than the generation
before
increased health care health span
better access to that is only true in
the shift from pre-industrial to
industrial so you get that once
uh well it depends upon how you apply
the lessons to your system in the case
of europe i'd say they got it three
times
but there's definitely an upper limit
one of the things to keep in mind
especially when you're talking about
european demographics is that europe in
europe people are not living longer
overall lifespan has not improved what's
improved is we've gotten rid of a lot of
mortality so the things that used to
kill you when you were zero to 65 don't
kill you anymore
right okay
that is going to change the shape of
demographics as well right the fact that
young people are able to get old more
easily say more safely more safely yeah
precisely so i guess there's just a lot
over the last 100 years we've seen such
change it's not just being technological
change but downstream from that is
what's happened demographically and how
that's the how that's influenced the
demography okay so if you're medicine
electricity sewage yep if china's got
the worst who what are some of the areas
that have got better looking demography
uh the three countries in the world in
the in the advanced world actually in
the advanced and in the developing world
um new zealand france united states
uh and largely for the same reason uh
they're countries that have a little bit
more physical space
so their cities tend to be more of a
sprawl you're more likely to have a
backyard more people can live in the
countryside and be economically viable
so when these three countries urbanized
they did it at a slower rate and they
remained the three advanced countries
with the lowest urbanization rates in
the world
in the advanced developing world the
closest one was is going to be mexico
and for similar reasons um
central mexico which is on a highland
massif
is just one giant suburban sprawl
and that means that people can have more
children now
all of these countries still have their
own demographic hiccups they all have
the baby boomer problem it's just that
they all have replacement generations
um i saw i had a conversation with
jordan peterson about this at the start
of the year and i did some research
before is the
country with the highest
current birth rate per family chad could
be somewhere in africa i'm going to
guess with the problems somewhere in
central africa yeah chad nigeria that
that cluster uh-huh but i'm going to
guess that just lots of children isn't
necessarily a good answer either because
you then lock yourself into potential
futures you can't birth any more or
fewer five-year-olds now it's what
whatever happens this year
yeah precisely precisely precisely so in
the case of sub-saharan africa and you
know this is a
very broad array of countries it's very
difficult to make a generalization
they've started to industrialize
and so they're going down the same path
that everybody else did and the first
step of that path is lowering infant and
child mortality and so when one out of
three children don't die
you have an explosion in your birth rate
but if you play that forward 10 15 years
then you start having adjustments in
family planning and you get smaller and
smaller families as urbanization kicks
in
the danger for countries that are in
this category who've taken the first but
not the second step
is that they've imported a lot of the
technologies of industrialization which
has helped them out but they have not
developed the systems to sustain that
themselves
so if something happens to the outside
environment they lose all of the
benefits well like
healthcare medicines fertilizers
it's very easy for me to see a lot of
these countries facing famine in the
not-too-distant future because if you
break down globalization you know yes
that means it's difficult to get oil or
manufactured goods i'm more concerned
about agriculture
agriculture is by far the most delicate
and vulnerable of the economic sectors
because it needs the equipment it needs
the finance it needs the fertilizers it
needs the trade options you break any of
those the whole system falls apart
and with the ukraine war we are seeing
massive disruptions to the fertilizer
sector with some of the decisions the
chinese have made same thing
so we're already looking this year at
losing
roughly a third of global fertile like
fertilizer supply that is going to haunt
us for a decade
wow okay so for the people that maybe
haven't been able to work out why it is
that increasing urbanization and
education and development causes a
reduction in birth rate can you just
explain that sure it's a wide array of
factors so when you move into a city you
have less room and that just changes the
mechanics of raising kids
when you move off the farm kids are no
longer free labor you have fewer of them
when you urbanize when you have
electricity you've generated time and so
people can do things after sunset this
is important for everything in terms of
economic development but it's most
important for women
because if a woman moves off the farm
and into the city and all of a sudden
can do something after hours
you have the opportunity for mass
education and freeing them from doing
more than just being mothers nothing
wrong with being a mother but it's a
full-time job on the charm in the city
you're going to have fewer kids that's
less time allotted and you have a
greater chance to you know read
and so the entire women's right movement
is basically linked indelibly to
electricity
and once you have it women have fewer
kids because they now have other things
going on in their lives that compete for
attention um they can go and get jobs
they can pursue careers they can do
research yes interesting we absolutely i
mean the the british example with the
the cotton mills was probably the best
example the first group of people to
urbanize weren't the men it was the
women and we saw the impact on
birthrights
going back to what you said there about
food shortages and the delicacy of
agriculture i'm seeing a lot of videos
uh come out shaky phone videos come out
of china at the moment just how bad
is there any uh reliable information
about how bad food and the future of
food will be in china
it's getting difficult to get good
information out of china it's really
demand
devolved into a cult of personality
state even stricter than what mao zedong
had
i don't think that the chinese having a
food crisis that is impacting their
ability to have calories at the moment
chinese land is among the worst in the
world and so it requires a huge amount
of fertilizer to grow anything
specifically phosphate for rice it's by
far the world's most phosphate hungry
crop in the chinese traditionally
because of that have been the world's
largest producer and exporter of the
stuff
the problem is actually with african
swine fever now you may have heard of
that a few years ago they had a big
outbreak they ended up culling molar
hogs from their farms and the rest of
the world's commercial
farms have hogs
just give you an idea of just how
lopsided the pork market is it's
two-thirds of it is china
they went to rebuild their herds but
they never abrogated the debts for the
farmers who went out of business they
just offered subsidies to bring in new
people they thought that would be
cheaper
well you have now two million new hog
farmers in china who have no idea what
they're doing and let's just say that
phytosanitary does not
translate into mandarin well in the
first place
so we're probably in the early stages of
a second wave of asf that'll probably be
just as bad if not worse than the first
one so pork just like it did two three
years ago is about to fall off the
market in china completely
that just leaves rice
so the chinese have banned the export of
phosphate fertilizer
in the short term this is causing
massive problems in agricultural
producers in east and south asia
australia especially western australia
is probably the part that's gotten hit
hardest
brazil is feeling the impacts these are
western australia and brazil basically
can't grow without fertilizer they don't
have soil in the way that we think of
the term it's a weird geology
but
you interrupt the input flows
and it's very difficult to grow food at
volume
and china in the best of times is on a
razor's edge in terms of food
sustainability and they use about three
to six times as much fertilizer as is
used in the global average just because
their land is so poor
uh
luckily phosphate they've got covered
they produce that themselves but the
nitrogen is all made with imported
natural gas
and the uh
the phosphate half of i'm sorry the
potash half of that comes from a
different continent
so
yeah china demographic collapse
unavoidable
food collapse highly likely
and that's before you start talking
about things like energy manufacturing
and trade
does this not make china unbelievably
dangerous
the question is what would you do if
you're china where would you go to get
what you want
if you go into kazakhstan fine but you
know what does the winner get you can't
go to india
himalayas are in the way
you could go into vietnam but
when the vietnamese when the i'm sorry
when the chinese did that last in 1979
they got treated just as well as the
americans were and so that was a quick
war
they don't have the navy to push out
japan and taiwan could go nuclear in a
month hang on that just leaves russia we
heard
does
china are taking over the south china
sea there's all of these small island
debts that they're putting together
they've got this scary big
armed
forces that's going to come and take
over everything in the is that not the
case so they're not as strong militarily
as they have been have we've been told
really not um they have made significant
strides over the last 30 years i don't
mean to belittle that but everything
they're doing in the south china sea was
designed to intimidate vietnam and the
philippines into cowering and it had the
opposite effect and both countries just
ran to japan and now have defense packs
it doesn't really allow the chinese to
project power very far either
they do have a lot of ships they've got
like a 650 ship navy but
90 of them are really small and can't
sail more than 1500 kilometers from the
coast
and that assumes they're going slow in a
straight line and no one's shooting at
them in actual combat conditions they
can maybe make it 600k
so it's they don't have the power
projection
and they're the country in the world
that is most dependent on reaching the
world in order to reach markets
and resources
okay so that's demographics how does
globalization play a role
well
if the chinese can't reach europe they
lose their largest market if the united
states throws a trade war they lose
their second largest market if they
can't reach africa they lose raw
material resources if they can't reach
the persian gulf the lights go out
they are completely dependent on
globalization as maintained by the
americans for the entirety of their
economic and cultural system what do you
mean when you say as maintained by the
americans
the united states is the country that
guarantees freedom of the seas or
traditionally that has been our role
since world war ii that's what we're
getting out of
and we're
there's going to be this little fun
thing with ukraine war that's about to
happen so i don't know how much you've
been following that but the europeans
have done an insurance ban
which has dissuaded most reputable
carriers from taking russian crew to
china so the chinese and the russians
rented a bunch of super tankers lashed
them together into a raft off the coast
of portugal and they're bringing shuttle
tankers from russia's ports which can't
take super tankers and doing c2c
transfers in the middle of the atlantic
i i can't wait for somebody just
just grab it
it could be portugal the chinese don't
have the naval capacity to put anything
that far out either to the russians but
someone soon is going to do that that's
going to shut down the entire energy
trade out of russia i'm a little
surprised it hasn't happened already but
it's going to be a fun day when it does
go down dude that's wild i mean how much
how much oil are you talking about here
because presumably if someone was going
to do a small act of war in order to
take it it would have to be a worthwhile
amount of uh you wouldn't you probably
wouldn't do it just because you wanted
the oil you would do it because you want
to disrupt the russian financial system
because this would destroy it
one super tanker the insurance policy
and one super tanker is going to run
about a billion dollars
the russians only have five billion
dollars put aside for this so not only
would you disrupt the immediate transfer
which probably would affect
i'm just spitballing here because the
russians aren't talking but let's call
it two to three million barrels
immediately but anything else that was
in the chain going back to the russian
ports probably another 10 or 15
million i'm sorry i said billion earlier
two to three
million barrels there's probably another
10 to 15 million barrels on shuttle
tankers on their way there now
and then all of a sudden the ports get
clogged and then the pipes get clogged
and the pressure builds up into siberia
into the permafrost and the wells freeze
and that's it for russian energy for 30
years
dude everything is so interconnected
and fragile
okay so that's globalization for china
you mentioned that the us was kind of
like the police of the sea
and they're getting out of it what does
getting out of it mean and what did
police of the sea mean
well part of globalization was making
sure that everybody's commerce could go
anywhere and the pre-world war ii
environment unless you were an empire
with a navy you didn't trade you
couldn't because the empires were in
charge
when the empires died in world war ii
and the americans took over the global
structures
we decided that rather than having a
single american-led structure that was
designed to siphon off energy and food
and resources and money to the united
states as an empire would we would
instead
prioritize security versus the soviets
and so we provided the economic backdrop
the security backdrop that was necessary
for everyone to play and that's the
world we know that's what we've been
living in the americans make sure that
piracy is under control they make sure
that hostile countries can't reach
commerce and they generally provide
policing actions uh not to say that
we've done it great at any given day but
that that's been the plan and it's
broadly worked
since 1992 we've been backing away from
that we've been closing down our
overseas bases we've been retooling our
military so it's not destroyer heavy and
designed to patrol it's carrier heavy
and decide to and uh designed to hammer
things
so we now have 11 super carriers by the
end of this decade we'll have 14.
one of them
is more powerful than all but nine of
the air forces on the planet
and that assumes a fair fight and the
whole idea of a navy is it's never a
fair fight
because ships move
you know we learned this from you
and so it's really one of their new
super carriers can take on any but one
of three air forces in the world and we
are going to have 14 of them
so that's great if you want to knock off
a country
if you want to patrol the global oceans
no no no no because you can only be in
14 places at once and that assumes
they're all at sea which never happens
so we no longer even have the military
structure
that is necessary to guarantee global
commerce
no country in the world does
so the most likely outcome of this is
we'll get a series of regional powers
that have military force that is capable
of kind of making a bubble a little
sphere of influence
and there will be trade within those
bubbles
but the trade between the bubbles is
going to be very very sketchy
difficult to regulate difficult to
protect and by definition can't really
be very long distance
that eliminates a lot of what's out
there
what are you protecting
the seas from is this
criminals and people that are going to
steal ships is is that the risk that
happens i'm trying to work out the
difference between the current state and
the state where there are a few
destroyers patrolling the seas well
pre-world war ii was usually imperial
competition
if you didn't have something that you
thought you needed you went out and you
took it and if somebody else had it you
had a nice little war with a naval
component
during the cold war it has been i'm
sorry just during the post-cold war era
piracy has come back in a very big way
it's
more an irritant
but if you look back to pre-world war ii
privateerian was all kinds of fun
and the idea that you didn't have to go
out and raid your opponents shipping
yourself you could just hire someone to
do it
i expect to see a lot more of that oh so
that was what i was thinking i was
thinking this sounds very
primitive very medieval that
countries that
publicly are at peace and
have their
diplomats going to visit each other and
conversations and they're sat around
tables together agreeing about stuff
that they would try and steal
shipments of potatoes or whatever it is
that's going on or metals that seemed a
little bit unlikely but what you're
saying is that
there are ways around committing
outright acts of naval war
by you can have state piracy basically
using your military to grab things
direct you can have privateering where
you rely on third parties to do it and
provide safe harbor
and then you can have flat out piracy
we've dealt with all of them in the past
we're going to have to deal with all of
them in the future do you think that's
is that realistic though in the current
state where
information is able to be pushed around
the world super quickly and sanctions
and public
lambasting and so on and so forth would
someone really come out and try and
steal some ships whether under the cover
of
a bunch of guys
russia's been doing it for six months
okay yeah
yeah
they are at war though right when you
break down the rules of action and when
you remove the security guarantor
countries do what they feel they need to
whether it's out of opportunity or
desperation
interesting okay so that's globalization
globalization let's say that it does uh
start to slow down what are the knock-on
effects of that oh dear god okay
uh so i just wrote this book
uh the book split into six big chapters
based on the various economic sectors so
transport finance energy industrial
commodities agriculture manufacturing uh
everything that we understand
about all six is dependent upon the idea
of global security and so you remove the
global security and all six of them have
to unwind and reform in different ways
so really it's kind of pick your poison
with transport long haul goes out the
window
that's an end to among other things
super tankers so if you are getting your
oil from 3 000 or more miles away
you're out of luck
um
ships are going to have to be smaller
and go faster because the concentrated
risk that a giant container vessel has
you lose one of those and the shipping
company goes away
if you're doing smaller tankers or
smaller ships that are going faster they
can't carry as much you just lost most
intermediate goods trade that's an end
to electronics manufacturing in its
current form
so you can play this on really any topic
that you want but the structures that
have all held it together and made it
work are dependent upon the ceiling not
falling
and it's falling
it seems to me like the current way that
the world set up has got most people
myself included to believe that
everyone's just a bit nicer now
than we were for most of human history
do you understand what i mean i totally
do uh how would you say
it's
global policing masquerading as
virtuous human nature
we established penalties for people who
didn't play
and because the americans started with
europe which was the headquarters of
most of the empires
it stuck
the only non-european empire that
mattered at the time was the soviet
union which was the target of all this
and japan which was subjugated
so everyone who in the past had been a
bad actor if you want to use that very
loaded term all of a sudden was on the
same side everyone who had ever had a
projection-based military throughout
human history was in the same coalition
it worked
for a while
you've said that energy is one of the
sub components of globalization
presumably because in order to get the
energy you need to move it around the
world in order to take it from where
it's taken from to where it needs to be
used
is just how crucial of a port a point is
energy because alex epstein's been on
the show nate hagan's been on the show
richard betts from the ipcc has been on
the show i understand that they have
their priors with regards to where their
research lies but obviously their focus
is that especially with nate you know
energy is is absolutely everything what
are your views on the current sort of
state of the energy climate and then
moving forward climate change as well
i would say that there's not a lot of
light between me and those names i mean
obviously when you get into the details
analysts can quibble about everything
and they can they do absolutely uh but
the the core idea that without energy
none of this works is solid
um
we've spent the last 70 years bringing
the energy from where it's produced to
where it's consumed which means
primarily from the middle east to europe
and east asia north america is more or
less a self-contained component even was
before the shale revolution now it
certainly is
that was one of the prices the americans
paid in order to get their alliances
making sure the energy would flow
in the environment we're in now we're at
a risk of losing all russian crude
now i've always thought this was going
to happen eventually i didn't think it
was going to happen this soon
russian crude is what has largely fueled
the global economic expansion since 92
because when the soviet system collapsed
their energy production did not and all
of their commodities were just dumped on
the international market
and that has kept prices relatively low
for 35 years
that period is now closing and so we're
gonna lose
five percent of global crude which
doesn't sound like a big deal
until you remember that energy demand is
inelastic
and a five percent loss in crude can
easily generate a tripling in price
so an energy induced depression that is
broadly global in scope
will start because of the ukraine war at
some point
and this is probably the reason that no
one's gone after that raft yet
because that would be the death blow for
the russian energy sector so that would
kind of be like have you seen a
um
margin call the movie
not recently no but do you remember what
it was about is it a 2008 financial
crisis and it's it's semi-fictional and
they bring everybody in overnight and
they say look if you decide to do this
if you decide to dump all of everything
into the market you are choosing to
begin
the most armageddon like financial
situation that anyone's ever seen so
that that's interesting um that for
somebody to go and do that they're aware
that downstream
five degrees of separation there are a
bunch of externalities that are
basically going to ruin the whole system
yeah now
the math is going to be different for
everybody like take take latvia latvia
has the capacity to do this all they
have to do is grab one shuttle tanker as
it's leaving saint petersburg that would
do it and the latvians have already
managed to wean themselves off of
russian crude and while it would crush
most of their european partners they
would see the destruction of the primary
income stream for russia as an unalloyed
good
or consider the americans we're
self-sufficient we have the capacity of
putting a wall around our energy exports
so they stay at home
so we could actually see energy prices
in the us go down because of this
but then the rest of the world would
lose access to russian and american
crude at the same time
so everyone has their own math to run
and a lot of it is going to depend upon
how everyone interprets the loyalty or
the actions of their allies so i mean
look at germany the russians are in the
process of jerking with the germans on
natural gas and you know for those of us
and the rest of the world like yeah
natural gas it's an energy source
whatever no biggie that's not what it is
in germany the entire german economy is
based on taking cheap russian gas
processing into petrochemicals and then
using those inputs in their entire
manufacturing sector if they lose that
gas it's not just that electricity
prices go off it's that the german
manufacturing model fails
so the germans are being presented with
a choice
leave the coalition
and keep the lights on
or
lose your gas and no longer be modern so
what's more important to the germans
being western or being modern
that's a that's a [ __ ] choice
but it has consequences and people will
judge them done based on what they do
peter you need to give me something
positive here man i'm just i'm terrified
this this doesn't sound like a very good
situation
at all what what are there bright lights
what are some of the bright lights there
are countries that were damaged by
globalization uh the empire specifically
if you were a country that had a pretty
good geography at the start of this
then when the americans came through and
changed the rules so that everyone can
play you saw a massive drop in your
overall power
if you are one of those countries
and
you have a positive demographic
structure
you could actually make a lot of hay out
of what's coming because you could i
don't want to use the word imperial nero
imperial might be the right word
uh you can definitely make a bid for
your own neighborhood so uh the two
countries that are on the top of my list
as regards that are turkey and france
decent demographics good manufacturing
base largely not integrated into their
neighborhoods economically
the french actually trade less with the
eu than the brits do
fun fact um
and i can see part of western europe
becoming part of a french victim in
obviously parts of the middle east uh
for turkey i would have put japan on
that list
but the japanese managed to cut a deal
with both donald trump and joe biden
which makes the japanese the only people
who have been able to get on with both
sides of the american spectrum of late
so i think they've basically agreed to
partner up with the us rather than go
their own way which i think will be the
best for everyone in the long term
unless you're chinese of course
how's the uk going to do
that's up to you
you really need to figure out this
brexit thing
i mean it's just yes you've left but you
still don't have any plan for what's
next and that is really hurting you
uh with every day that that is pushed
off your negotiating power with whatever
the structures of the future
end up looking like are going to be
weaker and weaker and you're very
rapidly getting to the point where the
only option you're going to have is a
trade deal with the united states on
america's terms
there are worse things that could happen
but uh we will be as
it's best way to phrase this
we believe be as gentle in the
negotiations as we were during the lend
lease talks
where you basically had to give up half
of a hemisphere of military presence in
exchange for 40 destroyers that you used
to laugh at because they were so bad
not good it doesn't seem no it's not a
good negotiating position that's for
sure okay you think that mexico is going
to be a big part of america's future
also canada is good because it's over
yeah because it's able to do good
immigration it's able to keep its
demographics pretty well what's the
future for america look like in your
opinion well the united states is
starting this process with very little
trade exposure to the wider world
outside of manufacturing in asia
a net energy exporter of all forms
a the largest refining power in the
world the largest agricultural power in
the world so a lot of the things that
every single country in the world is
just gonna have to stress about us is
just kind of a no-brainer it's already
there uh in addition successful
manufacturing requires
proximate labor that is at different
skill sets and price points so the
person who's doing the injection molding
is not the same guy who's making the
microchip
with mexico we've got that already
so for us a lot of the hard work has
already been done and while i'm not a
huge fan of donald trump by any measure
his renegotiation of nafta was a stroke
of genius and it got ahead of a lot of
these issues
because of that north america's unit
looks pretty strong and we're already
seeing
established linkages to other powers
that might be useful so we for example
already have free trade deals with
colombian chile which are in my opinion
the two most dynamic south american
economies
we already have a long-term agreement
with both the koreans and the japanese
the australians have a free trade deal
with the united states and were in
league with the australians and the
japanese really starting to become
engaged with southeast asia which is
another part of the world where the
demographics and the geography line up
so that kind of
greater american co-prosperity sphere
is about as good as it's going to get i
mean you'll have to deal with the
americans we tend to be a little twitchy
sometimes
but we're twitchy in a different
hemisphere for most of the partners
which most people really like
in your neck of the woods france is just
going to be completely insufferable
because they're going to become the
broker for the germans they're going to
become the the first power in iberia and
in italy and they're probably going to
make a bid for the low countries too
and the longer it takes the uk to become
a self-sustaining power again
the more advantage the french are going
to have in rewriting the local rules so
a good example is that you know you've
you've built these two super carriers
they're top-notch pieces of equipment
but between budget cuts and austerity
and the financial crisis you let the
rest of your navy die
so you've got these two fantastic
vessels with no defensive rings
which means the only way that you would
ever let them leave port is if they're
sailing as part of an american battle
group
again not a good negotiating position
what ways could america mess this up
oh so many so many
uh we're in one of our once in every
generation or two political reshufflings
and as long as that is going on we
really don't have eyes for the rest of
the world so there's a huge strategic
and economic opportunity here for the
long run if the united states would
chose to lead and kind of define what
the new world was going to be
what i've outlined here is probably
what's going to happen on autopilot and
in many cases because the australians
and the canadians and the japanese are
doing most of the diplomatic heavy
lifting thank god they're there because
it would be a mess otherwise
one of the great things to keep in mind
about the united states is because the
population is so big and so young and
because the land area is so huge and so
fertile we've never had to be at the top
of our game
we can rely on geography and demography
to do most of the heavy lifting for us
and that allows our politics to be
completely batshit
uh
and that's where we are now there are
many degrees of freedom that you can
mess up within yes uh this this isn't
france where if you screw up
you have to pay for it for two
generations
if the u.s population is big and young
does that not mean that downstream from
that you need to have an even bigger
younger
population in order to not end up with
that inverted pyramid shape on your
demographic it's definitely possible um
while most of europe and japan and korea
have that v-shape in their demographics
ours is more of a double hourglass
because we've got a bulge where the
boomers are and then a bulge where the
millennials are but then a big cut out
for gen x and a big cut out for the
zoomers
the ins and outs of that are going to
dominate our economic and our financial
world for forever
so right now we're about to go through a
capital crunch
in 15 years when the millennials are in
their 50s we will be going through a
capital boom
as a rule large generations make large
generations and small generations make
small generations so we would expect
this
wave to continue
what that means is that the american
propensity for overdoing things and then
over correcting
that's just part of our dna now and it's
backed up by our demographics that will
take us
all number of bizarre directions and we
will drag along a lot of other countries
with for the ride i was with jonathan
height a few months ago at the heterodox
academy conference and he was talking
about the
dangers in the dating market for gen z
at the moment the high levels of social
anxiety the fact that you've got one
third of people aged 18 to 35 are still
living at home with their parents the
number of 18 to 30 year olds reporting
no sex has tripled in the last 10 years
from about 10 to 30
a bunch of things that are causing young
people to be less socially out there
presumably to have children later i
think it's 2019 that for the first time
ever more women had children over the
age of 40 than under the age of 20. for
the first time ever in history more
women at the age of 30 were childless
rather than with child so all of these
things
seem
like they would predict a ever aging
generation or an ever-ranging uh
demographic
what your suggestion is that you have
this sort of hourglass shape and there
will be some sort of inflection point
presumably with the
15-year capital boom
should hopefully encourage
more families more children more
population
offset this going from an hourglass into
a inverted pyramid that's what the data
we have today suggests but i i've gotta
underline we're in uncharted territory
here the world has never had a
population bust uh without having some
sort of massive endemic disease or war
event
uh so when i say you know the chinese
collapse has to happen you know i don't
know how you make it work without kids
or young adults when i say that the
americans are going to experience a
another baby boom as the millennials
really come into their own
history and data suggests that but we've
really never seen this combination of
factors before
the zoomers
i have concerns
they are not like millennials
millennials are very outgoing they're
very social
because they were raised by the baby
boomers and they were always told that
they were special that's one of the
reasons why a third of them still live
at home
the zoomers were grazed by gen x my
generation
and we took a very different view of
things you know we kept track of the
score at the soccer game we wrote it
down we showed it to him before each
game we read it to him to bed so that
they wouldn't forget and when they turn
18 they're the hell out of the house
they're they're insular they're
competitive
don't like relying on anyone for
anything and so the whole group dynamics
and managerial dynamics that the
millennials are positively known for and
recognized for
they're the antithesis
their dream job is to code alone in the
dark in a closet
and that makes it hard to have kids
so i think we can guarantee that when
it's the zoomers time when they're in
their 30s that their birth rates are
going to be low their marriage rates are
probably going to be the worst we've
ever had their suicide rates are already
the worst we've ever had
which
just means that the millennials will
save us all okay right you're relying on
you're relying on me and my lot
fantastic given
given the current state and obviously
there's a lot of contributing different
countries what's going on with
demographics people talk about
population collapse overall globally
what is your view of global population
uh
before we start talking about
deglobalization so assuming that
globalization continues from its height
onward we were already in the process of
revising down our estimates
so it used to be 15 years ago that we
thought by 2050 we were going to have 11
to 12 billion people that number is now
under 10 and as the data continues to
get upgraded we'll probably
assuming nothing goes wrong
peak at just below 9 and then start
falling back gently
if i'm right about deglobalization
we're going to have a significantly
sharper drop-off and as soon as
globalization hits agriculture at large
which may be in the fourth quarter of
this year
population peaks
wow okay positive stuff uh
looking at the ways in which
population collapse and the reduction of
that could be tied in with automation
is there any
technological savior that can come
through and assist us with the problems
that we're facing at the moment there's
always unknown unknowns when it comes to
technology i'm aware of that but
are there things that you can foresee if
we get particular advancements that may
alleviate some of this absolutely so
pros and cons uh there are a lot of
technologies with automation ai and
robotics that look really good now ai
the whole idea of general ai and skynet
we're decades away from that so i was
put that in the box i'll let ian musk
talk about that
ai is all about image recognition today
and getting it so that machines can
recognize different things and then
do pre-programmed tasks there's no
there's no real autonomy but it's
automated
that allows manufacturing to reshape but
it also requires massive economies of
scale the most expensive thing a country
can do isn't industrialized it's to
automate
and it's not a one-off cost you have to
constantly update it because every time
there's a change to the production line
you more or less have to start over with
the programming so it's a very expensive
way to go it does use different labor
and less labor but it's not clear to me
that it really moves the needle in a
huge way
and if we're breaking down
global transport and intermediate goods
trade then we're losing the economies of
scale that make that model work
in north america where you've got one
third of global consumption
we'll probably still be doing that but i
see that broadly leaving the east asian
sphere
which combined with their bad
demographics are awful
we also have the baby boomers leaving so
we know that the capital crunch is
coming that means less money is
available to do this sort of upgrading
uh the the technologies i'm most
interested in
are the combination of automation and
agriculture we're very close to having
facilities that you can latch onto a
tractor
that identify each individual plant
and identify if it needs water or
fertilizer or pesticide or if it's a
weed or whatever and then it gets a
squirt of whatever is appropriate so you
do like six passes of stuff in one pass
and each plant gets individual attention
that suggests that we would be able to
reduce fertilizer and pesticide use by
80 percent
and maybe even double yields
but again economies of scale
it only works on mega farms where you
can afford the equipment cost so if
you've got giant farms in the united
states or the netherlands or argentina
or australia
sure
doesn't work for most of the world
talking about technology i've heard that
we are unbelievably reliant on getting
cheap technological parts out of china
silicon chips and other such stuff
how much of an issue is it going to be
if china is facing demographic collapse
and then can't make anything anymore how
much is that going to have downstream
effect for the rest of the world's
technology
well we've been a little bit lucky that
the chinese have kind of become a bag of
dicks and really
encouraged everyone to outsource and
resource everything that they can
uh it's that's bought us a lot of time
now in the united states everyone is
paranoid about semiconductors and we all
see that 12 percent number that the us
now only produces 12 percent of global
chips as a panic point but that's by
number
by value we produce 60 percent
so all the food ships are designed in
japan the united states they might be
manufactured somewhere else if they're
further down the the scale
uh but in terms of cell phones and
server farms the important stuff that
that's already safe uh the problem is
going to be the mid and the lower land
the mid ones are usually malaysian
thailand the lower ones are almost
certainly china
so when you're talking about the lower
tech stuff the internet of things yeah
that's just going away but i'd argue
that i don't really need a meat
thermometer that is going to tell my
phone what the temperature of the meat
is i mean we can get by without that i
think
it's overall electronics manufacturer
that's going to be the big issue because
remember
differentiated labor forces is what
makes manufacturing work china is a huge
place it's got a lot of that internally
and then it has access immediately to
taiwan japan korea and southeast asia
that's what's breaking down that whole
ecosystem
we can't rebuild all of that i mean
just
just to serve
electronics needs for north america
probably would require a workforce of 4
million people in manufacturing we're
already in labor shortage
and the mexicans are kind of tapped out
already so there is going to be a huge
amount of pressure
americans do well at the really high end
manufacturing
and the very low end because we're
energy rich it's the part in the middle
that we're really relying on the
mexicans to save us for
what ways could you be wrong about all
of this stuff you know
like i said this is perspective we're
dealing with an environment that we've
never been in before
the way i would like to be wrong
is that the americans would actually do
what george herbert walker bush wanted
to do back in 1991 and have a
conversation with ourselves about what
sort of world we wanted to live in and
how to get there
we weren't interested then
i would argue that we're really not
interested now so that the risk here
from my point of view is that
globalization does manage to persist
because of some lingering american
commitment
i'm not seeing that i'm certainly not
seeing that with ukraine war yes we're
seeing nato having a new lease on life
but the whole guns for butter deal that
we made during the cold war
none of the economic stuff is on the
agenda all the sanctions that the trump
administration enacted are still there
with one exception that the airbus case
uh
i don't see it's very likely and then on
the demographic front that's just math
if you want more 30 years 30 year olds
you had to start 31 years ago
what difference would it make if china
invaded taiwan
uh that would probably lead to the end
of the chinese system as an
industrialized economy in less than a
year
why that's fascinating
it's an open question of whether or not
the chinese could pull it off
and with the ukraine war we finally got
some good signposts of what it might
look like the chinese have always
assumed that the war would be a walkover
that no one else will get involved and
that china is such a big place that
everyone will just suck it up and move
on well that clearly hasn't happened
with ukraine and the united states and
the west have a much tighter
relationship with taiwan than they do
with ukraine
ukraine was only preparing for this war
for eight years taiwan has been
preparing for 60.
ukraine can you can walk to ukraine from
russia it's a bit of a swim to get to
taiwan uh the sanctions that are in
place against russia would absolutely
devastate china because while russia has
a lot of faults it's a major exporter
food and energy
china imports those things
75 percent of their oil is imported from
a different continent
and 75 of their oil is imported
and then i think it's really the
boycotts that have really scared the
chinese the most
the idea that individual citizens might
have any say on policy
they had they did not see that coming
they have no way to process that in a
one-man state because it's so different
to the setup that they have yeah exactly
so every assumption that they've based
the last 40 years of military planning
on has proven to be wrong
and then of course there's the question
of whether they could actually do it
if they did a slow-motion mobilization
like the russians did it took three
months the taiwanese would see that
they built a few nukes
and so
the cost of capturing taiwan would be
losing shanghai and beijing
that doesn't seem like a good plan so
the only battle plan that i've seen that
might work
is if they just text every member of the
army and say go to a port get on a
fishing boat and sail
you'd lose a million people in the
crossing
just to get to the beaches
so there's nothing about this that works
and if they did pull it off even if they
do capture taiwan they are now cut off
from global manufacturing global
investment global energy and global food
trucks stop running within a couple of
months the lights go out in less than
six and that is all she wrote remember
agriculture is an industrial sector so
you're talking about mass famine in
under a year
dude
now normally i'd say the chinese aren't
stupid they wouldn't do this but it's a
one-man show now and nobody wants to
bring g any information because they
don't know how he'll react he's shot the
messenger literally so many times that
everything is a surprise to him
yes i understand what you mean i suppose
there's a lot of criticisms around the
fact that the vote of a stupid person is
worth as much as the vote of a
well-educated person in a democracy but
the problem is if you condense all of
that
power down to a single individual the
decision of
an angry or grumpy individual is the
same as them on a good day or them if
they were less idiotic or somebody else
had got to power so yeah i suppose it's
a
forcing function that condenses all of
these things down to one individual
human that is just as fallible as the
rest of us maybe even more human is
perfect
every time okay
but even a minor mistake just cascades
through the system and it's a full cult
of personality so you know we've got
basically people who are zealously
trying to do what they think she wants
them to do and just one of the more
inane ones is seeing teams of people in
hazmat gear disinfecting airport runways
because they think that's what you have
to do for covid just that
people talk about the americans now in a
fact-free zone that's nothing compared
to what's going on in the chinese system
okay so what do you think uh for most of
the people that are listening to this uk
us some in australia what is life going
to be like what is the quality of life
going to be like over the next 10 to 20
years what can people expect well the
next five years are going to be rough we
basically in the west need to at least
double the size of our industrial plant
um let me correct that in the west minus
germany
germany is its own special case uh
everyone else has largely hollowed out
their manufacturing as part of
globalization we focus on the really
high-end stuff and the design but a lot
of the middle and the lower stuff is now
done in other countries that's got to
change if you are part of a network
where you can access lower skilled labor
like the americans are with the mexicans
great if you're not you either need to
attach yourself to another system
or find some way to go without
now if you are in that kind of friends
and family network of the americans
energy is covered
food is covered investment will be tight
but available
and there's a degree of security that
you won't have in the rest of the world
so the biggest problem is going to be
building out that industrial plant
that means we should expect inflation in
the u.s of maybe 9 to 15 percent for the
next five or six years
because that's what it's going to take
to get through this
and if we do succeed at building that
industrial plant over that time frame
then that inflation rate will come down
and we'll have supply chains that are
shorter simpler cheaper and closer to
the end consumer so better all around
so if you're part of that network
and you can get over that hump it looks
pretty good
if you decide to go your own way
things are going to get a lot tougher
unless you are one of those regional
powers who actually has the geography
and demography to make it work
france
after the financial collapse of say the
euro
might not notice the rest of the world
going to hell
their manufacturing is already in place
their energy system is fine they've got
oil just across the mediterranean
they're going to have subsidiary
economies in spain and italy it's a
fairly good setup
that means that cost of living is going
to increase that means cost of energy is
going to increase quality of life going
to go down i mean are we going to see
civil strife in your opinion what's
going to go on i think we'll see a lot
of governments collapse but again it
depends upon where you are
the americans will always complain more
than what the problem is worth
and the fact that we're going through
our political transition at the same
time we're doing this is you know
awkward to say the least uh we're going
to blame a lot of things on a lot of
things that have no direct connection
that's very american
uh if you're talking about britain
that's up to you guys
he's like you know if you can figure
this out and figure out a relationship
with the united states or the french
before the break that would be your best
bet
is that because
after the break bargaining power goes
through the floor yeah exactly
now is the time to cut a deal you've
just had a change in government the
ukraine was hot and heavy
if you were going to have a leader take
the country in a more sustainable
direction now is the time
if people want to keep up to date with
the stuff that you're doing with the
work with
uh keeping themselves abreast of all of
everything that's happening at the
moment where should they go
uh the website is
z-e-i-h-a-n dot com and if you go to
that slash newsletter you can sign up
for our video logs and newsletters
they're free they will always be free
peter i appreciate you thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]